we start today with new recommendations
from the southern nevada health district
this morning it released a statement
recommending that both vaccinated
and unvaccinated people wear masks in
crowded
indoor places where they may have
contact with others
who are not fully vaccinated this
includes places like grocery stores
malls
large events casinos and airports
well these new recommendations come as
covid cases rise nationwide
it also comes as california also makes
some new recommendations and changes
you might recall yesterday health
officials in l.a county
asked people to reconsider traveling to
places with high infection rates
like here in las vegas l.a county will
also reinstate the indoor mask mandate
for
everyone regardless of vaccination
status starting tomorrow
at 11 59 p.m dr montu davis
says l.a has a rapid increase in
coronavirus case numbers
and concerns over the delta variant i do
want to recommend that especially if
you're unvaccinated
reconsider traveling to places where the
seven-day cobra 19 case rates are
increasing we're
high like nevada our neighbor or
missouri florida arkansas
louisiana among others you can check the
cdc data tracker web page for more
information on other locations
the next big question will other
counties follow la's lead regarding
their latest recommendations
here's where it gets a bit confused a
confusing federal guidance recommends
the opposite saying fully vaccinated
people don't have to wear a mask
while indoors